[Musique]
le mariage de crem alcool et sucre c'est
gourmand et riche à soi et c'est de plus
en plus québécois
on se coule qu'on rêve on revisite les
succès du passé après la vodka et le
jean nicolas duvernois a succombé aux
charmes des boissons à la crème et a
créé avec dominique g de chocolat favori
une autre crème québécoise la crème je
crois qu'ils étaient sous le radar très
souvent la crème et dans le café ou chez
soi on fait pas de bruit autour d'une
crème mais là la crème essebag comment
je pourrais dire la couleur le cacao
qu'on utilise à cause de son acidité est
un peu moche et ça y est pas chocolat au
lait comme on a l'habitude des grosses
compagnies de chocolat au lait j'imagine
recherche et développement de goûter à
tous les autres il y en a beaucoup de
bonnes wire si on a vraiment beaucoup de
bonnes moi j'ai tous les produits chez
moi je bois tous les produits mois une
crème d'une entreprise québécoise n'est
pas compétitif moi si on n'achète pas
sur coup franc je suis d'accord il va
pas acheter belize m'achète une autre
femme qui croise très fier d'avoir
développé ce produit
[Musique]
la saq a observé un bond de 150 % des
ventes de crem québécoise croissance
généré principalement par l'arrivée de
cinq nouveaux produits l'automne dernier
ici au québec canada de la d'inscrits
dont ceux ci une catégorie de produits
qui répondent parfaitement à ce besoin
on est la clientèle cible québec on
effectivement la dent plus sucrés que la
moyenne canadienne mais aussi un grand
consommateur de produits laitiers donc
si on dirait que ça a été inventé pour
le marché le marché québécois presse
mais la mère de toutes ces crèmes
alcoolisées c'est la crème irlandaise et
c'est assez fascinant comme histoire
c'est un coup de génie commercial
c'est un petit groupe de créatifs
alimentaire dans les années 70 1973 à
londres qui se sont fait commandé par
une entreprise de distribution d'alcool
irlandaise alors créé un alcool
l'histoire vue quand 45 minutes top
chrono ils ont développé le concept pour
le belize donc se sont dit si on prend
un produit laitier de la crème ce que
nous avait un peu de cacao gaborik qui
était dans un placard avec du whisky
irlandais et ça a donné
la base ce qui allait devenir un empire
de nos jours la crème servant de base à
ces produits alcoolisés vient de crime y
création une entreprise néerlandaise
ayant des usines aux pays-bas et aux
etats-unis
c'est une crème qui a été développée qui
est stable à qui ne va pas se défaire au
contact de l'alcool
c'est un leader mondial 100% des crèmes
sur le marché c'est cette entreprise en
phase avec lui on n'a pas d'autre choix
surtout que quand on a une entreprise
comme la nôtre qui exportent des
produits faut que ce produit loi soient
en forme tous les marchés convient à
noter que parmi les crèmes québécoise il
y à crème érable qui est végal le les
remplacer par un liquide obtenu à partir
de noix il existe aussi des crèmes à
base de plantes ou de fruits qui ne
contienne toutefois aucun produit
laitier
c'est simplement une la dénomination
pour les lis car quand on a encore plus
de sucre que les locales traditionnelles
tellement de ce grand fait que le la
texture devient plus souple presque
comme un sirop et c'est à ce que fait
référence le mot crème mais ça n'a
jamais vu une bâche de sel dans les
crèmes québécoise le degré d'alcool
varie entre 15 et 18%
je vous dirais que 17% degré d'alcool et
c'est pas simplement le goût aussi très
souvent ça vient avec la taxation parce
que la taxation se fait souvent sur le
pourcentage d'alcool qui est dans un
produit tous les pendants des marchés
encore une fois c'est bien complexe
l'industrie l'alcool mais disons que
j'aurais voulu choco crème à 40% des 70
dollars pour pouvoir faire ne serait ce
que quelques dollars sur la bouteille il
faudra débourser entre 29 et 39 dollars
selon l'ama évidemment ces produits
contiennent aussi des ingrédients sucrés
mais ce qui donne l'identité à chacune
ses l'aromate konya joue l'érable est
une des saveurs brisé c'est d'ailleurs
avec ce goût typique que le coureur des
bois a été un des premiers à se lancer
dans l'aventuré des crèmes en 2010
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça permet justement d'aller chercher des
des notes
on vous en avait un qui beaucoup plus
sur le ce cas la crème le chocolat la
crème glacée fondu les classiques
anglais l'érable donc après ça je
voudrais on peut avoir chacun sa petite
with de plaisir coupable qui viennent
chercher vraiment pour ajouter sept ans
souvenirs d'enfance à toi
qui peut être une de ces savoirs leurs
que ça se rapproche le plus en les yeux
fermés la saison c'est la recette du
super g de ma grand mère
le chef pâtissier jacques moret aime
beaucoup lui aussi ses boissons au point
où il en met dans des dessins ou moi
j'ai s'est désintégré depuis quelques
années déjà
souvent on va s'en servir pour parfumer
certains desserts rehaussé certains
arômes qui vont exploser quand y voir
une touche d'alcool à l'intérieur d'un
capteur italie le côté qui remue ça qui
est vraiment mis de l'avant sinon on va
y rajoute un aronde dedans qui dans la
dans la crème d'amaretto minieri lui
c'était vraiment le plus facile à
travailler
ce qui est agréable c'est le but de marc
et hop c'est le petit clic de l'alcool
la panna cotta avec l'écran il faut y
aller délicatement voir qu'est-ce qu'on
peut remplacer dans notre set parce pour
arriver au bon équilibre film
pauline chômeurs avec le coureur des
bois crème le crémant à glace c'était
plus difficile un peu mais comme lille
et souvenirs d'enfance qu'on a le visuel
s'enrichit chaque rom la cbk console
mais en bourse ont même déjà
l'impression de ce que ça vous goûtez
par la suite le fameux sans vie de
jacques roumain glace qui dégouline un
peu comme le mano sur notre enfance toi
ton plaisir d'enseigner ou les déguster
par l'assiette